[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of Fandango indie
movie Guide coming to you this week from
the streets of Austin Texas for the
South by Southwest Film Festival and I'm
sure you're all hearing about the big
buzzy titles that are played here at
South I like atomic blonde with Charlize
Theron or the disaster artist with James
Franco but I want to walk you through
some of these smaller tiny indie titles
that you should be looking out for free
fire has a big cast including army
hammer and brie Larson but it is an
indie directed by Ben Wheatley who Tube
kill list and sightseers this one is an
action thriller comedy hybrid all set in
the 70s with in one location of a
warehouse and it's about a a gun dealing
that goes horribly wrong or horribly
right as the case may be so much fun to
watch with a packed crowd lemon is a
film that played at Sundance I finally
got to catch it here at South by
Southwest it's directed and co-written
by genex at Bravo and it also is also
written people just yelling at me from
the street also co-written by Brett
Gelman who stars in the film this is
kind of the antithesis to lala land it's
about an actor trying to survive trying
to make it in Los Angeles but a very
very dark looked at what la is like some
funny moments to a very unique vision
janessa has she's definitely a filmmaker
to put on your list of ones to watch and
I love the style I love cameos by
Michael Cera and Judy Greer plays a role
too so great cast
flesh and blood is probably my favorite
film that I've seen here at South by
Southwest it's a time
I really hope it gets distribution so
that everyone can see it it's directed
by and stars Mark Webber you might
recognize from Scott Pilgrim vs. the
world but as a director he has been
making these very personal films for a
while including
the end of love which starred his young
son this one stars his mother and his
brother it's about a man returning home
to Philadelphia after being in prison
and trying to rebuild his life but more
than that it's a look at addiction and
look at poverty and it's a look at
characters that we don't normally see on
screen because many of them are actually
real people talking about their actual
traumatic events that have happened to
them personally it's very easy to
empathize with the characters and very
real and raw and we'll get you right in
the heart
fits and starts is by another female
filmmaking that you should look out for
called Laura
Teru so she co-wrote hello my name is
Doris and fits and starts is her
directorial debut she also wrote it
which is fitting because it's about
writers it's about a husband and wife
who are both writers he is struggling
she's much more successful so it's all
about that dynamic and how that plays
out within a marriage funny sharp and
one that I think would be perfect to
watch at home when I say the words
coming-of-age summer film you probably
roll your eyes because that's been done
to death but I promise you hot summer
nights is something unique it is the
directorial debut you might notice the
theme by Elijah Bynum and it has a
fantastic cast including Timothy
Schemmel a who I think is going to be a
huge star as well as Michael Monroe if
you would recognise from movies like it
follows and what happens is it shows the
end at the very beginnings and so the
whole film you're working towards that
inevitable conclusion it's tense it's
thrilling and it's also very truthful at
the same time
so I'd love to see more from Elijah
Bynum note down hot summer nights as one
to watch lucky is a film by another
first-time director it's does Harry Dean
Stanton it's been said that Harry's face
is a landscape and not just a face that
fits so well because he's playing an
aging guy who's on a sort of spiritual
journey towards the end of his life it's
funny as well and features and
incredible performance by David Lynch
and speaking of David Lynch David Lynch
the art life as a documentary playing
here at South by Southwest and this is
such a treat for any Lynch lover
it shows a behind-the-scenes look of his
life all told by Lynch himself and a
look at how he creates his art so you
see him with his hands in paintings and
putting things together and it's so
incredible to watch he is an true
artists through and through if you are a
film geek like I am I urge you to seek
out David Lynch the art life and as well
as those Indies of course look out for
Edgar Wright's baby driver this movie is
so much fun it's an action thriller
getaway heist film all set to music
choreographed to music I'm sure it'll do
very well for Edgar Wright and it was so
exciting to see it with a big crowd here
in Austin and that's it from the South
by Southwest Film Festival thanks for
coming on the streets of Austin with me
the crazy crazy streets of Austin
hopefully I've given you some Indies to
look out for hopefully you'll eventually
get to see them and I'll be back home
next week I'm Alicia Malone I'll see you
then
[Music]
you